I'm Travis Roby I'm 50 years old I'm a
truck driver by day and played Smith by
night
I love blade Smith and because I can go
out to the garage and I get in the zone
just focus on what I'm doing it's nice
to see something that you create come
out of the steel and last forever
my name is Cameron LaFrance I am 20
years old from Warner Robins Georgia I
got into Metal Works thanks to my father
he early on was saying I'd be a welder
or someone who plays with fire it's
really what sparked no pun intended my
drive for working with metal and Fire
my name is Mike Powell I'm from Hastings
Florida I make blades as often as I can
usually a couple hours in the morning
before work and then as much time as my
wife will let me on the weekend she
sacrifices a lot of art one-on-one time
for me to be in my shop making blades if
I win the 10K I'm going to get my wife
something nice that we can enjoy
together
voice Miss welcome to the forge you guys
see we've got a bunch of different Tools
in here and I want you to each use at
least two of them to Source your steel
for your blades we've got hammers we've
got chainsaws we've got band saws monkey
wrenches you name it with whatever tools
you guys choose I want you each to
create a pry bar knife which means one
end needs to be wedged and work as a
functioning pry bar you need to be set
up for a Full Tang and we want to have a
blade that measured between 11 and 13
inches keep your eyes on the clock do
your absolute best work you will only
have three hours in round one of the
competition and that time starts now
right off the bat my game plan is to get
a hold of those bandsaw blades I know I
want to make a canister and I don't want
to try to put any thick heavy tool steel
or the Hammers or any of those bits into
the can I wanted that thin material that
I could get in there with that powder
first thing is get white out in that can
and let that white out start drying so
that I know my can is going to separate
I absolutely have no intention on
leaving that on there
so I'm looking at the steel and it's
some good some bad but I see the bandsaw
blades and the hand saw I know for a
fact that that's harmable Steel
I looked over at the crate and I see
some pipe wrenches so I decided to
switch over to the pipe jaws and using
the leftover of that hand saw I plan to
do a layered Damascus Billet you want to
go ahead and put the band saw blades in
the center core where my Edge is going
to be make sure I got more than enough
for this blade as I'm looking to see
what's left I decided to go with the
handsaw and files and make a canister
Damascus
I'm going to take it casual and that's
my plan just slow and easy have to get
this can off of this Billet so I take it
over to the chop saw and I'm going to
cut the ends off so I can actually see
the seams let's see here I find the
seams luckily this thing actually starts
peeling
I've got enough of this can off that I
think I can take this thing to the
grinder now and grind what's left off of
there yes it's in the Forge I'm thinking
man if I put it in a press I can see it
separate a little bit maybe I can get
the press to help me
I think he got some of it peeled
so for my design I want something that's
going to have a nice strong spine I need
the edge on the tip for prying and
something that's not too thin for
chopping so I cut the tip off I'm
starting to foraging the bevels it's got
an angle so that you can wedge in and
pry with it so I get on my ruler and I'm
measuring my blade up and as I'm looking
at it I'm like maybe an inch and a half
short
I'm in trouble I've got to stretch this
thing out
so the hammer I'm using I brought it's
called a flatter and it keeps things
flat instead of running over to the post
place you give it a couple whacks I've
used it time and time and again at home
and it works fantastic before quench I'm
at 11 and a quarter not a lot of room
but it's there I'm gonna get this blade
quenched
I like the sound of that I'll take this
thing to the grinder I'm gonna get as
much done as I can before that clock at
zero I got my blade to length and I got
my handle sorted out enough and so I get
ready for my quench
nope
as I'm trying to skate the file I feel a
digging so I go in for a second glitch I
got a lot of voices in my head that tell
me not to do this but I've got to get a
hard blade
[Music]
it's not skating
third time's the charm oh boy that's bad
I'm starting to think did I choose the
right steel against better judgment go
for a third quench
and this time it skates a little better
than before that's just gonna have to
work
the judges won a pry bar knife so I'm
going for a Cleaver type blade or the
flat end on that 90 degree corner and
I'll be good
if I get it up to temperature I get into
quench
I don't hear any cracks I don't hear any
pings I'm good bye
five three two
two machines put down your tools round
one is over
well guys congratulations the three of
you are moving forward into round two of
our competition where you'll fix any
issues you guys have with your blades
and add handles turning into fully
functioning knives now unfortunately for
you guys other than pin stock the pantry
is off limits but the good news is
somebody left me a chainsaw
oh
all right gentlemen this log here is the
only material you guys have available
you guys have two hours in round two to
complete your handles and that time
starts now
first thing in round two that I'm gonna
do is get my handle scales established
so I take my chisel and start beating
the ever living crap in the center of
the log
finally
pop finally my plan is to split the wood
as much as I can without having to grind
too much you know it's
whistle to break off the pizza that he
has they look like pretty good little
scales already I've got my scales cut
I'm trying to drill these holes I'm
still having no luck at this press
doesn't want to cut it all
it's not a [__] man I don't want to
mess around with this thing so I'm like
well I'll sharpen this bit I do it at
home all the time
I get back to the Press
the bit cuts right through like butter
no problem Hallelujah problem solved
just like that
now that I got both my scales I'm going
to fit up my handle I'm praying it with
each tap that it does not crack
one thing done time for the next so I
put the epoxy in the first scale I'm
lined up and I pick up the other scale
and automatically I grab it swipe with
some epoxy
oh crap I'm on the wrong side
oh this could be all bad I take
everything to the grinder and I just
cleaned it up the glue is off the handle
and now I'm just going to put this thing
back together and get it together right
I'm looking a bit delamination right at
the end of the tip and I know that it's
going to be tight I can't grind too much
I have less than a half inch room I
cannot go below parameters I have got to
get this blade just right get rid of
that
I refuse to go home on parameters five
four three two
Bulls round two is officially over
bladesmiths Welcome to our strength test
our ladder pry and Shop
I'm going to take your blades drive them
under these metal plates and try to pry
them off
then after that
I might just beat the hell out of the
ladder for a while how's that sound
absolutely don't act so thrilled
remember you signed up for this
Mike you're up first you ready to go
absolutely let's do it all right let's
go
I'm like you survived good job biggest
problem I had though is this tip it
didn't come to a like a chisel point or
anything like that so it's harder to
drive it under that plate
handles a little lean but it's not
uncomfortable
and everything's still together and
tight good job thank you
Cameron oh
I'm sorry I'm sorry I thought you'd like
dead in my eyes it scared the crap out
of me I'm sorry
foreign
[Music]
Cameron you survived good job
this isn't ground down to a zero Edge or
even close so it was a little trouble
driving it in but once I got it under
there that plate popped right off no
problem your Edge is still good
good work thank you very much
your turn buddy
he looks thrilled
not good
okay Travis you never know what's going
to happen these competitions that was
the last thing I expected
your blade held up great no problem
there but your handle scales came off
you can see that
the male threads aren't even coming
about halfway through you might have a
thread holding each one that's about it
and that's why your handle came apart
Travis you were able to fix the issues
with the blade after round one but
unfortunately your handles fell off
during the testing phase and
unfortunately that makes the tool no
longer testable and for that reason
we're gonna have to ask you please leave
the forge
good fight
I'm disappointed in myself I should have
known better
I'll just go home and get back to the
forge and keep on doing what I love to
do I made it this far I made a solid
blade I'm happy I'll be all right